a new report claims the drug company
accused of helping engineer and profit
from the opioid epidemic also considered
expanding into addiction treatment the
ProPublica article is properly based on
a seek on secret parts of a lawsuit
filed by the state of Massachusetts
against Purdue Pharma and members of the
Sackler family who own the company the
suit alleges Purdue deceptively sold
oxycontin and downplayed its dangers
Purdue says it will continue to defend
itself
Tony Jacobo has been closely following
this story Tony good morning good
morning well according to ProPublica
blacked out portions of the lawsuit show
that Purdue Pharma accused of causing
addiction also wanted to capitalize on
addiction treatment the article cites
internal correspondence between Purdue
Pharma executives discussing how the
sale and treatment of opioid addiction
are naturally linked república goes on
to report while oxycontin sales were
declining the internal team at Purdue
touted the fact that the addiction
treatment market was expanding
ProPublica
specifically names Kathy Sackler as
being involved with a secretive project
called Project tango which was allegedly
meant to help Purdue break into the
addiction treatment market the redacted
documents also reportedly show that
Richard Sackler complained over email
that a Google Alert was giving him too
much information about the drugs dangers
imagine that in a statement Purdue
Pharma called the release of this
redacted information part of a
continuing effort to single out Purdue
blame it for the entire opioid crisis
and try the case in the court of public
opinion rather than the justice system
now the state of Massachusetts according
to a court order has until midday Friday
to release blacked out portions of the
lawsuit so who released it early well at
this point it's unclear the attorney
general's office in Massachusetts told
us wasn't them and in fact they would
not confirm the contents of the
ProPublica article
bianna of course under you'll continue
to follow this story thank you